hey guys I wanted to create a important video on
the seven surprising things that can kick you out
of ketosis now you may know the typical things
like sugar you know and refined carbohydrates
but these are things that you may not know
that are important number one stress can kick
you out of ketosis because stress activates a
hormone called cortisol cortisol is the main
adrenal hormone that adapts the body to stress
so any type of stress shock to the system even
a surgery trauma allergies even the loss of a
loved one can activate stress stress on your
job relationship stress boom that can actually
knock you out of ketosis I bet you didn't know
that one next next one is excessive caffeine now
one cup of coffee is not going to do anything but
if you're doing coffee all day long or tea
all day long with caffeine too much of that
connective eight adrenaline which can then
activate insulin alright bone broth in large
quantities now a little bit of bone broth is
not going to be an issue but we're talking to
protein protein will activate it it can bump you
out I'm not too concerned about bone broth even
when you're fasting it may knock you out a little
bit but it's a very very small amount so I'm not
too concerned about that whey protein is one of
the top proteins because it's low fat and high
protein that will stimulate insulin and knock you
out of ketosis and then we have l-glutamine now
that people take that for your digestive system
leaky gut irritable bowel syndrome it's a it's
a protein and it can knock you out of ketosis now
I'm not concerned about you taking that because it
really helps you in certain ways it's not going to
put weight on but the only reason I bring it up is
because as you tense yourself and all of a sudden
you get knocks you out don't be concerned that's
what's doing it it's going to be a temporary
thing but it will knock you out okay and then
we have MSG monosodium glutamate another name
for that is modified food starch it's in so many
foods and it's easy to avoid if you're shopping
but it's very hard to avoid if you're going out
to restaurants because they have it in the sauces
they have it in the dressings they have it in the
in some of the flavor enhancers on Peruvian
chicken loaded with MSG so they've any food
that just tastes too good typically has msg on it
especially if it's the fast-food restaurant next
one artificial sweeteners aspartame Splenda that
has actual dextran and it also has maltodextran
that will not give out and saccharine these are
artificial sweeteners that can raise insulin so
another interesting hidden thing and then excess
that protein will do it to let's say you have this
big steak and that's why the Atkins diet which is
high in protein they're allowing too much protein
that can spike insulin and knock you out of
ketosis so ideal sweet spot for most people
between three to six ounces per meal all right now
if you're actually doing two meals a day or one
meal a day and you're trying to do them at fasting
where you're just condensing that to from three to
two to one and you keeping your calories higher
maybe you can get a get away with like eight
ounces of protein you know but typically it's
three to six now if you just as a side note if you
combine sugar with protein you will majorly spike
influence so that's even worse than excessive
protein next one is to mini keto desserts now let
me just explain this I always recommend taking
like one maybe two but not a whole bunch so if you
cannot just have one then don't make them because
you're in the keto desserts you're going to add
mannitol or maltitol or xylitol or erythritol
some of these sugar alcohols now erythritol has
a glycemic index of zero stevia has a glycemic
index of zero xylitoll has a little higher
glycemic index mannitol and multiple has even
higher glycemic index now it's a lot less than
sugar but it still can affect insulin a little
bit I personally consume xylitol in very small
amounts but if I put it in the keto desert I'm
not going to do massive quantities of these keto
bombs which are little cookies that can really
knock you out of ketosis so again just because
it says it's keto friendly doesn't always mean
it's keto friendly in large quantities okay cough
syrup has hidden sugar as well alcohol beer juice
those are all the kind of the known things that
these are the things that you may not be aware
of so if you can think of anything else that could
knock you out put it down below I want to I want
to know what you think thanks for watching hey
guys I have a quick survey question what is your
biggest health challenge right now something that
is just bugging you or stopping you from achieving
your goal just click the link below let me know
because I want to create a video on that topic